thanks for taking the time david to talk
to me
um so tell me a little bit about how you
got the role in the bubble
well i've known judd for for uh
ever i mean when i did when i did larry
sanders when i met gary shandling uh
judd was
23 year old i think his first job was
writing for
for uh sanders and uh
met him then and then um and i can't
remember the year i did it but i did a
movie with jay chasm called the tv set
and in that i basically played judd and
uh
because it was it was loosely based on
judd's and jake's experience doing
freaks and geeks
and um
in fact the the day we did the table
read
uh before shooting that movie was the
night of the premiere of the
four-year-old virgin and so it was very
weird because uh you know in the morning
judd was at the taylor i think it was
one of the producers
and uh i was just playing this guy named
judd apatow that nobody knew and then i
went to the four-year-old virgin and it
was like a revolution it was like oh my
god
this is comedy now you know it was the
it was
first like hard r
you know raunchy
comedy and i was like oh
you know judd is at the forefront of
something and then he became you know a
name an adjective
uh
a godfather of comedy and uh i'm glad i
played him before anybody uh really
cared what
he sounded or looked like and um
so you know we've been kind of like
intersecting just throughout the years
and uh
he called and said he wanted me to do
this and there was there was like it was
like an ensemble of like six leads and
i'd be playing an actor and you know
it's never my like dream to play an
actor you know because i think you know
we all do that a number of times
but you know i really dug the idea and
you know to be able to do it during the
pandemic kind of
about what it's like to to work during
the pandemic and
i i i just always wanted to get into
judd's uh comedic world you know in that
way and so i was happy happy to
to finally you know after all these
years
make an entrance
what was it like to work with him
especially after playing essentially him
well it's interesting because uh i
didn't i've never worked quite this way
it's very improvisational i mean i've
improved uh but i haven't
improv like on a movie set quite like
that and
a lot of it is is is jud judd's on a
microphone behind the monitor and he's
he's pitching he's he's throwing out
uh lines he's throwing out stories i
mean you know you'll hear something
you'll be
cameras rolling you're on set i'm
looking across at leslie manning we're
doing a scene and judd will yell
something that i've never heard before
about my character or anything like oh i
didn't know i did that but now i'm going
to say it
you know like when we were saying
i i said i'm sorry i [ __ ] your agent
and your manager
your lawyer you know it's like because
there's like a lawyer
and you're like
on your divorce lawyer and your divorce
letter it was like i was like oh okay
so there's it's interesting because i
think like
looking now now when i look at some of
judd's work you can see the kind of self
surprise that people have
in his uh in his movies and and now i
get it now because sometimes they're
saying things that they they didn't know
about their character and there's a kind
of like energy about that that's cool
and funny because
you know it's trite
the writers always say you know
if you surprise yourself you'll surprise
the audience and in some ways
just kind of getting at that sometimes
where he's like surprising the actor who
then surprises him or herself
in the moment and that can that can
create a kind of interesting
energy
it did seem to create um that energy on
set at least i mean you guys had such a
great um chemistry as cast
was that due to
the a lot of the improving or did you
guys get a chance to
to
kind of bond beforehand or
well
we had
i forget how long we quarantined but
maybe two weeks alone
but that was kind of zooming with the
other cast members
and then
after we started shooting we were pretty
much the only company that we had
because we would
continue to quarantine as best we could
and we were most of us staying at the
same kind of complex in in london
so we did spend a lot of time together i
didn't know anybody before that and i
became really really friendly with some
of the cast and like pedro prescott is a
good friend i i loved
fred and keegan
and uh leslie i knew but leslie was kind
of off with judd in in that in in their
world um
so uh it was
is a part of
i think the reality of quarantining the
reality of also we had all these dance
resources which was weird you know
because like
we had a lot of dance roles because none
of us
are dancers maybe maybe iris was you
know she's really good she maybe she
danced a little i want to say she's a
little because she was so much better
than than me but uh
it was it was nerve-wracking because you
know jim was like yes you know it's it's
not the kind of funny way you're bad at
it it's the kind of funny that you're
good at i was like [ __ ]
i'm way better at the kind of funny
where i'm bad at something
we had a lot of
dance roses and we'd hang out i mean
that and that was for the entire cast
you know 10 people you know and and
these
uh
people like veer
and and samson
that that are just so talented and and
maria you know that we never i never
would have spent that kind of time with
them off of set you know i just wouldn't
have
and it was kind of cool to be able to do
that
now that you've done some of this
tick-tock dancing any chance you want to
start a tick-tock of your own
no i i don't think there's any demand
for that either
i i kind of thought i was a good dancer
until i until i had to dance uh it was
it was it was one of my last remaining
delusions as a as as a human being like
yeah i could have been a dancer if only
i'd
been trained i was like no not true not
true
how did the um movie compare with your
real uh pandemic working experience
like you're doing cocaine off of
keegan's head for real i mean
yeah i mean you know the idea of snoring
coke off keegan's head is it's probably
it's probably frowned upon by the cdc i
would imagine that that kind of behavior
during a pandemic
uh is frowned upon but um
you know when we're in the bubble we're
all trusting that we're we're covered
free at that particular moment right so
um
you know aside from the crazy
shenanigans we get up to the actual like
nuts and bolts of
showing up in a mask
you know getting your makeup done by
people in masks going to set
having certain designated areas where
your you can be and where nobody else
can be
that's all
you know that's all netflix protocol and
probably
general protocol at this point and
it's amazing how normalized it becomes
you know at first you think oh god no
way i can't i can't work like this this
you can't be can't feel free can't feel
loose what do you do you just do so
let's see your sweet eyes then
what's this is that
that what harry does he's like
yeah
that kid is so funny
yeah
yeah um
all of them i mean judd
judd is such a nurturer and a a uh
identifier of talent you know and he's
so enthusiastic about
young talent you know
and
i'm just
very impressed by his uh generosity and
his uh interest you know
and and uh and all that and and
so many of those the british actors even
the guys that were playing the
the the mo the mopo uh uh dinosaurs you
know this
kind of greek chorus of dinosaur those
guys super talented like everybody that
everybody that judd would
have there that
you know i might not know
i would always go wow
that kid or even like the woman that
came to play the scriptures advisor
again i don't know her name but she had
one or two lines which is great
you know
so switching gears a little bit um
you just released your newest album a
few months ago any plans on touring in
support of that
yeah i'd like to you know we're just
kind of waiting to see what what is uh
what is doable you know i just i played
a festival in tampa last weekend so that
was the first time
played in front of an audience since you
know back then since two and a half
years and and uh since the before times
yeah
before times that was an outdoor
audience and you know as
i i feel as safe as as we can be now i
think
you know everything is constantly
changing obviously numbers are going up
but the virus
this particular iteration of the virus
seems to be less
way less lethal
even way less
you know
of a disturbance in your life more more
like a cold the kind of lies that people
told in the beginning in order to stay
open
uh is now true so
seems to be true that could you know
that could morph at any time you know
who knows but
um
you know i tend to play i don't play
like open air 60 000 seat theaters you
know
not because i don't want to but i i
can't
so i play
2 000 3 000 rooms and
you know that you would say yeah that's
a super spreader
so
we don't know i mean i i sang um
i sang
i sing a john legend song in this movie
uh
you people that
i just did with the kenya barris
director and
that was also netflix and
in order to
to do that and this is only
this was only uh
last december right it's not that long
ago
uh i had to
get to set early test
twice
two hours apart
and then when i sang
the room had to be empty it was like
they pressed the camera
and they run away
and i and i did it a few times just all
by myself with no no other actors there
and and then uh
and then they wipe everything down
and then we come in and then when the
actors are there
i could only mouth it i couldn't expel
aerosol so
that's how even just a few months ago
that's how you sing in a movie um
so i
yeah
i was like
and i was like this sucks
because i really
it would have been funny if uh i had
their real reactions while i was singing
but no i couldn't actually sing in front
of people and uh
and and adhere to the protocols of movie
making right now any updates on the
truly like lightning show for showtime
no no i mean we're kind of in a holding
pattern there um
uh it's still like my main
ambition and goal
is to is to bring that to a screen
um it's tough enough it's it's a it's a
it's a
it's a heavy
it's a heavy story but i think it's
i think it's really uh entertaining too
you know ultimately but but when you
when you outline the bare bones of it
it's like oh that's super heavy i don't
know i don't want to see that you know
people are all people are all uh
have theories about the kind of
entertainment that people want to see
during a pandemic but i i never i never
think that people change
you know i think people
like what they like uh
regardless of whether it's pandemic and
i think people like to say oh you know i
all i want to see is this because i
don't want to deal with
reality but until something really good
comes along i'm like oh finally finally
let's start joking about it
um is there anything else that you're
working on right now that you can
talk about
just finished a movie called the estate
with tony clare rfr ferris and
rosemary dewitt and ron livingston
i think it's really funny
and uh kayla monterossa who was in curb
your enthusiasm
uh
pet cemetery
i did i did that it's like the prequel
to all the pets
and uh
written and directed by
really talented young woman named
lindsey beer who i think is going to be
a force to be reckoned with so i i think
that's like that's going to turn out
really well
and um
can i ask who you played in that
in pet cemetery i play uh bill baderman
the the father
of a
young man i'm like the instigator the
whole the whole damn thing you know
but you know it's a very uh
at the heart of that story you know for
whatever
for whatever iterations it's gone
through and for whatever
horror stephen king does it's really
it's it's a it's a story about parental
love you know and warning and
you know it's it's
i can really relate to
the themes underneath it so i was happy
to
to play that okay well i think i should
probably let you go because i think i've
exceeded our time
but thank you so much i really
appreciate you talking to me and uh i
loved the bubble and um
yeah thank you for having my books you
can rotate them out of the way now
okay thank you thank you
you